the second method and we're going up in
terms of sophistication here right the
second method is called a check sum all
right as the name implies it has to do
with addition okay this parity check is
really just about counting odd or even
right so you're just checking up ones
and zeros but the checks are requires a
little more calculating power little
processing half
okay so how does it work let's let's
have a new message okay so suppose I
want to send you some actual text right
and there are 26 letters in the alphabet
so suppose I'm going to send your coded
message like sir
25:13 four okay so all of these
correspond to letters I'd I'll go what
they correspond to but this is the
message I'm going to say okay now just
as before suppose you and me are
communicating on network and we agree a
chemically is parity check but
furthermore you have to agree on what
kind of page it could be on could be
even and that kind of kind of changes
things right I'm you'll expect that all
of my messages need to right or wrong if
we disagree on what kind of perry check
we're using so in the same way what we
have to agree on for the checksum is a
number by which we divide by it okay so
I don't just pick between odd or even
I'm going to pick a number sighs okay so
for instance let's begin number size
like say 16 I just pick 16 cuts of
character all right so what's the
relevance of this how does it work well
a checks on first I'm going to take the
sum of all these numbers okay so when I
take the sum okay what I get is what do
I get I get 36 48 55 68 72 that okay so
you've calculated this you're about to
send this to me so first you take the
Sun the next thing you do is you look at
the number that we agreed upon and you
divide your son by this okay and what
I'm interested in is just the remainder
okay so when you divide 72 by 16 64 is
the largest multiple of 16 that can fit
right so I subtract 64 one left with is
a remainder of 8 that okay 8 so 8 is the
checks on right in a similar way to the
parity bit this number will get
transmitted along with your actual
message okay but again like the parry
bit I will recognize that this part
isn't part of your message this part is
just to help me know whether the rest of
the message is right or not okay
so let's consider what might happen if
you send your message to me but I don't
get this suppose I get this okay so one
of them has been altered okay and you
can see obviously when you take the sum
of this the sum will be 71 so the new
remainder so it should be aw the new
remainder should be 7 right right okay
so when I get this message and I look at
the end I'm like all on a second this is
wrong
your checks are doesn't match the rest
of your message is that exact the
checksum doesn't match the message that
it's sending I think question
okay it's got it's got different names
unfortunately so um you'd call it but
then you divide by its a divisor right
so the parity bit works on counting the
checksum works on addition and division
okay that's that's the principles or the
mathematical principle in which words
there's gonna be a different kind of
divisor for the next kind of check as
you'll see in a second but that has a
more technical moon all right now you
knew this message was wrong okay but
just like with the parity bit there are
going to be some wrong messages that
creep through right that you will still
think all right can you give me an
example what would I have to do to the
message how would I have to change it to
make it wrong but still slip
the Aero check good so it's similar to
the parity check isn't it right in that
this one went down by one well if I
increase another one by one like the Sun
will end up the same this is still going
to add up to 72 okay
so therefore the remainder should still
be 8 so even though this message is
wrong it will still get passed by the
checksum check ok now this method I'm
suggesting is more reliable than the
parity check
why how can you tell straight away only
taking say the divisor is big why is
that crucial why is the size of your
right why is the size of the divisor
important and in fact the bigger the
dependents kismet the bigger the divisor
in better check yeah oh good so let's
have a think about this one right excuse
me the checksum right in our case we've
got eight what's the largest possible
checks on that you could get if my
divisor was 16 the largest possible
checksum would be 15 right you couldn't
get 16 because then I'd be able to
divide through my remain will be smaller
right you'll be 0 actually okay so
therefore in this case how many
different checksum possibilities are
there
well there's 1 through 15 okay and
there's also if this actually added up
to a multiple of 16 you could send 0 as
the checksum ok because then we remain a
0 therefore there's 16 different
possibilities for what the checksum
should be that means there's 15
different ones that I can know are wrong
ok because I know over here right if
this is 8 it will be right but if it's 1
to do 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 or 9 11 12 13 14
15 then all of those alternatives are
wrong ok so more possibilities for
incorrect values so this is going to
pick up
where's okay